Il y a bientôt dix ans,
j’ai passé un test
pour devenir prof de culture générale
dans un institut de préparation aux concours.
On m’avait présenté une copie de concours,
et on m’avait demandé
d’estimer la note.
J’ai dit que le fond de la dissertation
n’était vraiment pas terrible,
mais qu’elle pouvait bien
être notée
quatorze quinze.
Et effectivement,
alors que les gens pensaient
qu’elle valait moins de dix,
le correcteur du concours
l’avait notée
SEIZE.
Comment l’expliquer ?
Eh bien,
la copie se lisait
FACILEMENT.
Et comme je le répète souvent,
si vous écrivez
CLAIREMENT,
vous serez surnoté.
Avant que je vous révèle
mes trois secrets,
on doit se mettre d’accord
sur une chose :
qu’est-ce qu’un BON
style ?
Comme vous écrivez une dissertation,
votre style doit être bon
POUR LE CORRECTEUR,
qui est votre lecteur.
Eh bien que veut-il,
le correcteur ?
Il veut pouvoir vous lire
TRÈS RAPIDEMENT
et vous comprendre
TRÈS FACILEMENT.
Et ça,
ça sera possible
si vous écrivez
TRÈS CLAIREMENT.
Le correcteur ne doit JAMAIS
pouvoir hésiter
en vous lisant ;
AUCUNE AMBIGUÏTÉ
ne doit l’arrêter.
Votre objectif,
c’est qu’il vous comprenne
INSTANTANÉMENT.
Conclusion :
améliorer votre style
en vue de la dissertation,
ça veut dire le rendre
TRÈS CLAIR.
C’est un moyen efficace
de progresser RAPIDEMENT
en dissertation,
mais ça ne relève pas
de la méthodologie.
Si vous voulez progresser
en méthodologie,
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
C’est un cours par e-mail,
donc continuez de regarder cette vidéo,
puis vous découvrirez
mon cours de méthodologie après,
ou dans les prochains jours.
Là tout de suite,
écoutez-moi ATTENTIVEMENT
et vous saurez PRÉCISÉMENT
quoi faire
pour que vos prochaines dissertations
soient surnotées.
Moi aussi,
j’étais comme vous.
Quand j’étais étudiant,
je voulais impressionner le correcteur
— donc j’essayais d’employer
des mots compliqués,
du jargon philosophique
ou économique ;
je me prenais la tête
pour créer des tournures
« LITTÉRAIRES »,
et ça donnait des phrases aussi longues
et compliquées.
Quel est le problème
avec cette tactique ?
Le problème,
c’est que la complexité,
c’est l’échec GARANTI.
Ça l’est ENCORE PLUS
en dissertation,
parce que c’est un exercice
avec une contrainte de temps :
votre épreuve dure
un certain nombre d’heures,
donc vous ne pourrez pas
vous relire pendant des mois.
Donc le premier secret
pour améliorer votre style,
c’est de viser
LA SIMPLICITÉ.
Vous devez tout d’abord
viser la simplicité
SUR LE FOND.
Manipulez EXCLUSIVEMENT
des idées que vous comprenez
et que vous maîtrisez.
Ce que vous expliquez
dans votre dissertation,
vous devez être capable
de l’expliquer à un ami.
Comme l’a dit Einstein,
« si vous ne pouvez pas l'expliquer
SIMPLEMENT,
c'est que
vous ne le comprenez pas assez bien ».
Bien sûr,
ça veut dire que c’est À VOUS
de faire l’effort de comprendre
les idées de la matière
EN AMONT,
EN PRÉPARATION
de votre épreuve de dissertation.
Ensuite,
vous devez aussi viser la simplicité
SUR LA FORME.
Vous pouvez faire plusieurs choses
pour écrire simplement.
PREMIÈRE chose :
manipulez EXCLUSIVEMENT
des mots que vous comprenez
et que vous maîtrisez.
Évitez dans la mesure du possible
les mots techniques,
le jargon,
et préférez les mots
de la langue ordinaire.
Voici quelques exemples
de simplifications du vocabulaire.
DEUXIÈME chose
que vous pouvez faire
pour écrire simplement :
préférez les phrases courtes.
Elles sont statistiquement
les plus claires,
et vous risquerez moins
d’être maladroit.
La règle que vous pouvez suivre,
c’est de mettre un point
à CHAQUE FOIS
que vous pensez
à en mettre un.
N’hésitez pas,
choisissez la sécurité.
Alors bien sûr,
il ne faut pas non plus enchaîner
les phrases de trois mots,
mais ÉVITEZ
les phrases longues.
La TROISIÈME chose
que vous pouvez faire
pour écrire simplement,
c’est de vous passer des adverbes.
Un adverbe,
c’est un mot généralement invariable
qui nuance de diverses manières
le sens d’autres mots.
Vous devez surtout vous méfier
des adverbes en -ment,
comme « lentement »,
« extraordinairement »,
« particulièrement ».
QUATRE-VINGT-DIX
pour cent du temps,
ces adverbes n’apportent quasiment rien
sur le plan du sens,
et ils alourdissent la phrase.
Stephen King les compare
aux pissenlits :
si vous n’êtes pas vigilants,
vous aurez des adverbes partout,
et votre dissertation sera
pénible à lire.
C’EST TOUT
pour le premier secret.
Souvenez-vous
que pour écrire simplement,
vous devez manipuler
des idées que vous maîtrisez,
employer des mots
que vous comprenez,
rédiger des phrases courtes,
et éviter les adverbes.
Allez,
on passe au deuxième secret !
Vous pensez qu’ils viennent D’OÙ,
les mots que vous écrivez
dans une dissertation ?
Pourquoi croyez-vous
que vous choisissez
TELLE
tournure de phrase,
plutôt que telle autre ?
Eh bien c’est très simple :
vous écrivez
ce que vous avez déjà LU
ou ENTENDU.
C’est une affaire
DE MIMÉTISME !
Si vous ne lisez QUE
des livres BOURRÉS
de jargon sociologique,
vous pensez que vous écrirez
COMMENT ?
Vous aurez probablement tendance
à IMITER
les auteurs que vous lisez,
donc à utiliser VOUS AUSSI
du jargon sociologique.
Du coup,
pour écrire CLAIREMENT,
vous devez lire EN PRIORITÉ
les auteurs qui écrivent clairement.
C’est ça,
le DEUXIÈME secret.
Au fur et à mesure que vous lirez
des auteurs qui écrivent clairement,
votre style s’imprègnera progressivement
des qualités des styles
que vous lisez.
C’est pour ça
que pour améliorer votre style,
vous devez faire attention
à ce que vous lisez.
Maintenant,
SUR QUELS CRITÈRES
faire votre sélection ?
Les correcteurs attendent
un style CLASSIQUE
et plutôt SIMPLE,
donc vous devez lire
ce genre de styles.
En français,
le style classique se caractérise
par ce qu’on appelle
« LE NATUREL ».
Ce qu’on veut dire par là,
c’est que l’écrit réussit
à produire une impression qui rappelle
LA SPONTANÉITÉ
de la communication orale.
Quand on vous lit,
on ne doit pas avoir l’impression
que vous avez fourni un effort
— c’est ça,
« le naturel » du style classique.
Et la manière la plus simple
de développer cette qualité,
ce n’est pas d’écrire
une thèse de linguistique,
mais DE LIRE
les auteurs dont le style
possède cette qualité.
Après,
moi je ne vous recommande pas
de lire les meilleurs stylistes
— en tout cas
pas tout de suite —
parce que le fond
ne vous plaira
probablement pas.
Vous avez donc plutôt intérêt
à lire des choses
qui vous intéressent un minimum,
ET
qui sont écrites dans un style clair
plutôt classique.
Je conseille généralement aux élèves
ÉMILE ZOLA.
Vous pouvez par exemple lire
« Au bonheur des dames »,
sur les débuts
de la société de consommation ;
Germinal,
sur la condition ouvrière
et la lutte sociale ;
ou encore L’Argent,
si vous vous intéressez à l’économie
et à la finance.
Je conseille aussi Stefan Zweig
— même si son style est moins simple —
parce que cet auteur stimule bien
l’intérêt du lecteur,
et qu’il écrit tout de même clairement.
Si vous lisez Zweig,
votre style deviendra plus littéraire
— ce qui n’est pas une mauvaise chose.
Personnellement,
je vous conseille les biographies de Zweig
:
celle de Magellan,
l’explorateur qui a réussi
le premier tour du monde ;
ou celles d’écrivains :
Montaigne,
Balzac,
Dostoïevski,
ou encore Freud.
Enfin,
je vous conseille aussi
de lire Jack London,
un auteur américain autodidacte,
parce qu’il a un style
à la fois simple
et imagé,
et puis aussi
parce que ses romans
se lisent facilement.
Vous pouvez lire « Martin Eden »,
qui raconte l’accession de Jack London
à la gloire littéraire ;
ou ses récits d’aventure,
qui sont à la fois réalistes
et dépaysants,
parce que Jack London
avait lui-même beaucoup voyagé.
Voilà,
j’en ai terminé
avec mes recommandations.
Après le QUOI,
j’ai une seule chose à vous dire
à propos du COMMENT :
essayez de lire un peu
CHAQUE JOUR.
Faites-en un rituel,
et lisez en étant très concentré,
en faisant attention aux mots,
parce que C’EST ÇA
qui vous permettra de vous imprégner
du style de l’auteur.
Allez,
je vous révèle
le troisième et dernier secret !
Que va-t-il se passer
si vous essayez d’appliquer
les deux premiers secrets
lors de votre prochaine
épreuve de dissertation ?
Eh bien vous serez très lents !
Vous saurez
ce que vous avez à faire,
mais vous manquerez DE PRATIQUE.
C’est comme moi au tennis :
on m’a appris à faire
un bon coup droit
et un bon revers,
donc je sais ce que j’ai à faire
pour réussir ces coups,
mais j’ai si peu joué
que je commets beaucoup de fautes.
Bon en fait,
c’est une règle universelle :
quel que soit le domaine,
vous avez besoin DE PRATIQUER
pour vous améliorer.
Pour améliorer votre style en dissertation,
vous devez donc RÉDIGER
des dissertations.
Là,
vous avez peut-être envie de me dire :
« Oui,
mais une dissertation,
ça prend beaucoup de temps
— on ne peut pas en faire
une par jour ! »
Je le sais bien
— c’est pour ça
que je vais vous conseiller
TROIS
petits exercices
pour améliorer votre style.
Le PREMIER,
c’est le plus rapide :
vous prenez une
de vos dissertations,
et vous en lisez des passages
TRÈS ATTENTIVEMENT,
en vous concentrant EXCLUSIVEMENT
sur l’expression écrite.
En vous lisant,
vous faites votre autocritique,
vous essayez de détecter les passages
qui manquent de clarté,
et vous imaginez mentalement
comment vous les amélioreriez
— vous pouvez aussi
noter des choses sur la copie,
si vous préférez.
Donc ce petit exercice,
c’est comme si
vous corrigiez vous-mêmes
votre expression écrite.
Ça peut être très rapide,
si vous ne lisez qu’un
ou deux paragraphes,
par exemple.
Le DEUXIÈME
exercice possible
est un peu plus long :
là vous ne vous contentez pas
de corriger mentalement un passage
d’une de vos dissertations,
vous le réécrivez
ENTIÈREMENT.
Soyez exigeants :
ne vous contentez pas
de petites améliorations,
transformez COMPLÈTEMENT
le passage
afin de le rendre extrêmement clair.
Enfin,
le TROISIÈME
exercice possible,
c’est de rédiger
UNE PARTIE
d’une dissertation.
Une fois que vous avez traité un sujet
et que vous disposez
d’un plan détaillé,
plutôt que de prendre plusieurs heures
pour rédiger la dissertation,
vous pouvez rédiger
UNIQUEMENT
l’introduction
— qui est la partie
la plus importante
de la dissertation —
ou bien seulement un
ou deux paragraphes,
si vous voulez vous entraîner
à rédiger le développement.
Ce troisième petit exercice
est le plus long,
mais vous en aurez généralement
pour moins d’une demi heure
— donc si vous voulez VRAIMENT
améliorer votre style
en vue de la dissertation,
vous pouvez faire cet exercice
chaque jour
(et comme pour la lecture,
vous avez intérêt
à en faire un rituel).
Et puis si jamais
vous n’avez MÊME PAS
trente minutes
pour vous entraîner,
eh bien vous pouvez faire
un des deux premiers exercices
à la place.
Vous connaissez maintenant
LES TROIS SECRETS
pour améliorer votre style
en dissertation.
Vous devez :
viser LA SIMPLICITÉ
(sur le fond
comme sur la forme) ;
lire EN PRIORITÉ
des livres dont le style
influencera POSITIVEMENT
le vôtre,
le rendra plus simple
et plus naturel ;
et enfin,
vous devez VOUS ENTRAÎNER
à rédiger des dissertations
avec les trois petits exercices
que je vous ai suggérés.
Vous gagnerez facilement des points
en améliorant votre style
avec mes trois secrets,
MAIS ça ne suffira pas
pour réussir vos dissertations.
Pour ça,
vous avez besoin
d’une méthodologie SOLIDE.
Inscrivez-vous donc
à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
comme d’habitude,
j’espère vraiment
que cette vidéo vous sera utile.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour améliorer votre style
en dissertation.